joining me now is Tristan levit attorney
for IRS whistleblower Gary shapley um
what's Gary's reaction
tonight he feels Vindicated both he and
Joseph Ziegler really took a huge risk
in coming forward they did it because at
the beginning of this year it seemed
like the case was dead notwithstanding
these very strong findings they brought
forward but this absolutely vindicates
the claims that they made which were
doubted by so many in part because they
were released to the public right as the
justice department announced the
sweetheart plea deal so this clear shows
that that plea deal was nothing but a
slap on the wrist and the stunning facts
that are in this indictment really also
V vindicate the investigative work of
these agents now Hunter's um attorney
appeared on MSNBC earlier today and was
asked about whether or not his client
was sober when he filed his most recent
tax returns here's his response was he
sober when he filed these returns I
don't know which year you're talking
about I certainly know that he was filed
for 2018 and 2020 I can't sit here today
Katie and tell you if there is a 25 page
tax return and there's one thing on it
that could have been relabeled as
something else that's not the
point are we supposed to believe he's
sitting there meticulously doing his own
taxes
really yeah it's laughable but it's the
the fascinating thing about this case is
that there's so much out there about
those that did help him to prep his
taxes and the assistance he received
from from others like Kevin Morris the
Hollywood attorney who gave him 4.9
million as Joseph zagler revealed
earlier this week so there's a lot of
information out there for the public to
see and judge for themselves a source um
who's close to this story told me today
that people should really focus on where
this money the outside money came from
that went to Hunter Biden that the
source of the money is something that's
kind of been overlooked do you believe
that that in fact is something that
needs more serious
examination it's absolutely significant
the indictment itself really goes into
what he spent his money on and what he
didn't spend it on his paying his taxes
but it doesn't go into where he got all
this money and of course that goes back
uh as the indictment covers in some
small portion to the 2014 and 2015 years
the burisma money where the statute of
limitations having expired there won't
be a deep dive into where what he did
for that money whether Joe Biden was
involved in that money and the same for
other money from China so those are
absolutely questions that Congressional
investigators need to get to the bottom
of um and Tristan I should say that
Hunter Biden did appear on a podcast
today and revealed um what he believes
is the source of all of his legal
problems watch this may not in every
aspect be a Russian disinformation
campaign but it has literally every
earmark of what the Russians
did really Russia Russia Russia
again I thought that was a joke when I
first heard it it sounds like one but
but what really isn't a joke is that the
the allegations that the whistleblowers
brought forward weren't just about hter
Biden that's not why the whist blurs
came forward it was because doj tried to
cover all of this up and so David White
riss right now is a special counsel but
we still believe there needs to be a
special counsel to investigate his
office's actions because he's the one
that completely turned around after
interacting with Biden Administration
officials and tried to brush this under
the rug uh that and the source of where
this money came from early where the
statute of limitations was conveniently
allowed to run Tristan thank you for
coming on tonight we really appreciate
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else